ونذكر مشاهدين ان برنامج الجزيره
التحقيقين خفيه اعظم يعرض اليوم لقطات
ولقاءات حصريه تكشف جانبا من كواليس كتيبه
جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
للجهاد الاسلامي وايضا مجموعه اعرين
الاسود في نابلس
مساء غدا الجمعه تمكن من مواكبته شراره
المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه وتمددها على
الرغم من استهداف الاسرائيلي المتواصل لها
والتقيدات الامنيه التي تواجهها
التحقيق الذي يحمل عنوان خارج الحسابات
تفاصيل تنشر لاول مره عن بعض عمليات
مجموعات المقاومه التي حدثت مؤخرا في
الضفه الغربيه
من المواجهه الامنيه المستمره على جبهات
عده بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه يا اول
الاحتلال ما خفي اعظم خارج الحسابات
ياتيكم على شاشه الجزيره
ومنصاتها المختلفه غدا الجمعه في العاشره